mit der Atomenergie haben wir da einen
Löwen im Käfig aber wir wissen nicht wie
lange der Käfig hält ist Kernspaltung
kontrollierbar oder eine ständig
drohende Katastrophe die Atomkraft das
Ende einer
Ära heute
es ist ein schwerer Fehler aus der
Kernenergie zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
auszusteigen eine Energie und
Technologie politische Sünde und eine
echte Gefahr für Deutschland dass wir
dauerhaft die Energieversorgung nicht
mehr sicherstellen können sondern im
Gegenteil bei wachsendem Energiebedarf
mit hohen Preisen und einer veränderten
Klimasituation nicht unsere Ziele
erfüllen können das hat ein sehr
schmerzlicher Tag weil erkennbar ist
dass die Entscheidungen der Ampel zum
einen gegen den definitiv erklärten
Willen der deutschen Bevölkerung
stattfinden und letztlich auch rein
ideologisch getragen werden
wir brauchen alle Energie um die
Herausforderung der Zukunft zu meistern
ohne Energie keine Zukunft Energie
einseitig abzuschalten ist am Ende der
falsche Weg
man muss auch sagen dass die deutsche
Bundesregierung scheinheilig erklärt mit
einer hohen Doppelmoral versehen ist
Atomstrom aus dem Ausland zu beziehen
aber die eigene Verantwortung nicht zu
schultern ist nicht akzeptabel
weltweit werden fast nur 100 neue
Kernkraftwerke auf den Weg gebracht
unsere Nachbarn Frankreich und
Tschechien begehen diesen Weg
gleichzeitig zu sagen in der Ukraine der
eine der Ausgangspunkte war die
Sicherheit der keinen Energie in der
Ukraine in den 80er Jahren zu sagen die
Ukraine der kann das Weiterlaufen die
sind ja noch ganz sicher und aus
verschiedenes aber in Deutschland
abzuschalten ist das unserer Sicht
falsch wer in Deutschland auf Kohle
statt auf keiner gesetzt versündigt sich
auch an den Klimazielen so werden wir
die Klimaziele nicht erreichen und Fakt
ist auch deswegen sind alle Länder die
auch stärker erneuerbare Energien weiter
setzen weiter darauf angewiesen auch
andere
Energieformen zu nutzen deswegen ist es
auch klar dass die Ausbauziele die
gemacht werden kaum realistisch sind das
berühmte deutschland-tempo von Olaf
Scholz ist ein sehr langsames Tempo es
geht lange nicht voran und die
Ausbauziele in der kürzerer Zeit jetzt
zu machen bedeutet eine Vers 7fachung
der Windräder und PV um fünffach bis
2030 kaum zu schaffen deswegen unsere
klare Forderung lasst die keiner
gelaufen die drei Kraftwerke laufen zu
lassen zu überlegen wie weitere
Kraftwerke reaktiviert werden können
nicht ein halbes Jahr sondern als
Sicherheitspuffer bis Ende des
Jahrzehnts bis all die gesamten
Klimaziele und Krisen überwunden sind
Sicherheit zuerst alles nutzen an
Energie was geht hinzu die Forschung bei
der Kerntechnologie weiter aufrecht zu
halten nicht so riskierendes gesamte
Know-how zu verlieren deswegen wird
Bayern habe ich den
Wissenschaftsminister beauftragt sowohl
ein Konzept zum Erhalt der
kerntechnologischen Kompetenz anderen
Universitäten zu gewährleisten als auch
neue Technologien zu nutzen sie wissen
ja man Durchbruch bei der Kernfusion
erzielt die Kernfusion die neue
Kernfusion in USA darf nicht
ausschließlich dort stattfinden auch bei
uns deswegen werden wir hier ein
Forschungs ein wissenschaftskonzept für
die neue Kernfusion vorlegen und prüfen
auch ob ein eigener Forschungsreaktor
für Kernfusion für die neue Kernfusion
in Bayern zu realisieren ist übrigens
gerne auch mit anderen Bundesländern
aber wir gehen davon
besonders weh tut in Bayern auch dass
dies natürlich auch die Abschaltung von
isa2 zum Nachteil genauso wie
Neckarwestheim zum Nachteil des südenses
des Süden lebt nicht nur von der
Energieversorgung sondern auch von der
Netzspannung der regionalen von dem
Strom der hier erzeugt wird fällt es weg
ist die Netzstabilität in jedem Fall
herausgefordert und besonders ärgerlich
Isa 2 ist eine der sichersten Anlagen
weltweit hier gab es keinen einzigen
Störfall das heißt eine sichere Anlage
in Krisenzeiten abzuschalten ist aus
ideologischen Gründen mag es sein dass
sich da einige Jürgen kritin freuen aber
es ist schlicht und einfach das falsche
Konzept der Weiterbetrieb wäre rechtlich
und sicherheitstechnisch absolut möglich
wir halten auch noch nicht bis jetzt für
das letzte Wort das letzte war der würde
keinen gehst nicht gesprochen zeigt
durch Krisenszenario im Winter sei es
dann auch für die Zeit ab 2025
wir halten eine Zukunft der keinen
Energie in solchen Krisenzeiten für
möglich wir werden hier in Bayern als
zuständige Genehmigungsbehörde
absolut rechtlich einwandfrei aber alle
Spielräume die rechtlich möglich sie
nutzen um die Zeitachsen nicht zu
beschleunigen sondern so zu gestalten
dass ein Revival der Kernenergie
vielleicht noch entsprechend möglich ist
ergänzen dazu natürlich setzen wir auf
erneuerbare Energien wie kaum ein
Bundesland die narrative die immer
stattfinden hat die Woche schon eine
Wirtschaftsminister und Energieminister
zurückgewiesen wir bauen Photovoltaik
aus wir bauen geht für mich aus wir
werden auch Wind weiter ausbauen und
gehen fest davon aus dass wir die
bisherigen Spitzenplätze bei
installierter Leistung in Deutschland in
der Dynamik nicht nur halten sondern
deutlich verstärken können trotzdem
erwarten wir von der Bundesregierung
auch hier Veränderungen zum einen müssen
erneuerbare Energien gleichbehandelt
werden es ist unfair und auch gegen den
Süden wenn Wasserkraft wenn Geothermie
wenn Biomasse nicht annähern zu
unterstützt wird wie beispielsweise der
Wind
es ist falsch wenn einige Bundesländer
neue Gaskraftwerke bekommen das Land mit
den größten Energiehunger weil es das
wirtschaftlich leistungsfähigste mit ist
nämlich Bayern keine neuen Gaskraftwerke
bekommt die wir dringend brauchen und es
ist zentral wichtig dass am Ende auch
Stromleitungen und auch
wasserstoffleitungen nicht nur im Norden
sondern auch im Süden gleichzeitig
gebaut werden wir haben dazu in den
nächsten Wochen eigene Überlegung noch
mal präsentieren wer den Süden abhängt
hängt Deutschland ab das ist definitiv
so deswegen sind auch
strompreiszonen erster und zweiter
Ordnung völlig falsch damit schwächt man
nicht nur den Süden sondern ganz
Deutschland weil Industriebereich eben
wie sie heute haben nicht überlegen von
Bayern nach Kiel oder oder nach Rostock
zu ziehen sondern wenn überlegen Sie das
Land zu verlassen sofern ist der
Gesamtschaden für Deutschland enorm
zusammenfassend gesagt
irgendwie ist es ein schmerzlicher Tag
wir haben uns gerade von den
Mitarbeitern in gewisser Weise
verabschiedet gleichzeitig ermutigt und
es auch bedankt die über Jahrzehnte hier
eine ganz hervorragende
sicherheitstechnische Leistung und die
Stimmung des können sich vorstellen ist
hier sehr traurig weil eine Anlage die
einwandfrei funktioniert Strom als einer
der drei Anlagen insgesamt für 10
Millionen Haushalte gut und zuverlässig
liefert wird das reine Willkür und aus
reiner Ideologie abgeschaltet sein
schmerzhafter Tag aber auch ein
motivierender Tag weil wir glauben das
ist nicht das letzte Wort das ist
zugegebenermaßen eine wichtige
Vorentscheidung ist keine Frage und ist
jetzt auch nicht einseitig zu verändern
aber mit guten Ideen und guten Konzepten
sind auch zum späteren Zeitpunkt
Kernkraftwerk der reaktivierbar
zugegebenermaßen je später umso schwerer
und umso teurer und eher die
Herausforderung genügend Personal zu
haben aber nicht ausgeschlossen und wir
sind der feste Überzeugung dass mit den
jetzigen Energiekonzepten Deutschland
hat das Eis auf dem das eigentlich
stabile Eis auf die in Deutschland
ökonomisch stand jeden Tag dünner wird
und jeden Tag mehr schmilzt die Welt
macht uns vor wie es gehen könnte wie
agieren
definitiv anders als der Großteil der
Welt und damit wird Deutschland am Ende
damit leider auch in großen Schaden
nehmen es geht zu Lasten des Wohlstands
es geht zu lastens der
Versorgungssicherheit und ehrlicherweise
auch zu Lasten des Klimaschutzes
2 der versündigt sich am Klima wir tun
es nicht vielen Dank
ja meine Damen und Herren auch als
bayerischer Wirtschaftsminister vordere
ich von dieser Stelle aus von der
Bundesregierung jetzt sehr zeitnah
greifbare Konzepte wie die
Energieversorgung der Wirtschaft
bezahlbar und sicher abgewickelt werden
kann dazu fehlen die Konzepte die
Strompreise sind deutlich zu hoch und
man muss auch sagen seit dem Ukraine
Krieg ist ja nichts mehr so wie es war
die ganzen abschaltszenarien basierten
ja darauf dass man sagte wir haben eine
sichere Gasversorgung haben wir denn die
sichere Gasversorgung jetzt haben wir
wohl Fracking Gas aber es ist ja nicht
garantiert dass die Leitungen aus
Norwegen und so weiter das all diese
Dinge belastbar sicher liefern auf Dauer
insofern ist jetzt mit dieser
Entscheidung zum kennen energieausstieg
einfach wieder die Säge angelegt und ein
weiteres Stuhl bei ihm am Ende haben wir
noch ein einziges Stuhlbein auf das
alles gesetzt werden soll also klare
Botschaft ich fordere in den
industriestrompreis von vier Cent der
muss politisch dargestellt werden können
damit die exportorientierte Wirtschaft
von Mittelstand bis zur Großindustrie
jetzt einigermaßen wettbewerbsfähig aus
diesem dilemm rauskommt und nicht dass
man jetzt abschaltet in der Hoffnung ja
es wird schon irgendwie weitergehen und
ich sage es ganz klar ich habe den
Eindruck dass einige grüne Ideologen
darauf hoffen dass
Industriearbeitsplätze weggehen dass die
Chemieindustrie sich Richtung USA
verabschiedet dann reicht es eventuell
mit weniger Energie auszukommen aber
auch das ist ein Denkfehler den der
Energie Hunger nimmt zu man rechnet ja
damit dass allein im Strombereich wir in
10 Jahren doppelt so viel Strom werden
benötigen wie heute Stichwort
E-Mobilität Stichwort Wärmepumpen und es
ist dann ideologisch aufgesetzt wenn man
hier jetzt die Wärmepumpe so propagiert
die dann mit Gas und Kohle Strom
gefüttert werden muss und verkündet das
als die große neue grüne
Errungenschaften also wir müssen hier
ganz klar jetzt auch zeitnah Praxis
taugliche Lösungen
Antwort bekommen von Berlin wir haben
aus Bayern den Vorschlag gemacht da über
die energieministerkonferenz hier in den
Industrie einen wirtschaftsstrompreis
einzuführen den Strompreis vom Gaspreis
zu entkoppeln und es ist gerade zu
lächerlich wenn jetzt die
Bundesregierung auf der einen Seite 30
bis 50 neue Gaskraftwerke Jahr für nötig
hält die stimmt zunächst mal rechnerisch
aber den Weg Richtung Wasserstoff nicht
konsequent gehen will und sich immer
noch weigert dass die heutigen Erdgas
Pipelines Richtung Wasserstoff überhaupt
umgerüstet werden dürfen also hier steht
man sich auch dort wieder im Weg jede
neue Alternative die kommen soll wird in
Frage gestellt und wir müssen auch
zugeben dass das Thema winterenergie
natürlich wollen wir das noch weiter
voranbringen aber auch nicht alle
Probleme lösen wird die 30.000 deutschen
Windkrafträder haben vor wenigen Tagen
weniger Strom erzeugt als ein einziges
Kernkraftwerk also wir können noch
hunderttausend Windkrafträder bauen wenn
beginnt nicht weht haben wir keine
Grundlast es sei denn wir machen eben
Speichertechniken dazwischen wir machen
Umwandlung in Wasserstoff aber das ist
alles mit sehr viel Vorlauf verbunden so
weit sind wir noch nicht und sich als
Deutschland einfach raus zu lehnen und
zu sagen okay dann kommt eben der
Kernenergiestrom aus Tschechien und
Frankreich der Kohlestrom aus Polen und
irgendwie wird schon weitergehen und der
Rest an Industrie soll verschwinden und
wir spielen dann Pippi Langstrumpf in
Deutschland das ist für einen
Industriestandort wie Deutschland keine
Politik und ich sage es ganz klar die
Grünen müssen runter von diesem
ideologischen Ross einfach stur des
Parteiprogramm abzuarbeiten hilft uns
nichts weil einfach die Situation heute
eine andere als vor dem Ukraine kriegt
im Thema der Militärpolitik fahren Sie
heute genau den gegenteiligen Weg wie
vor einem Jahr da sitzt auf jeden Panzer
mittlerweile ein grüner drauf zumindest
beim Foto und dem Thema der
Energieversorgung da bauen Sie den alten
Stiefel und erzählen uns die Kamelen von
gestern deswegen wir brauchen für die
Zukunft einen bezahlbaren
industriestrompreis wir brauchen
genügend Strom für die gesamte
Bevölkerung wir brauchen jetzt Vorfahrt
für grünen Wasserstoff wir wollen
natürlich auch massiv die Erneuerbaren
ausbauen aber allein das wird nicht
reichen und deshalb ist es ein Fehler
hier und heute zu sagen wir steigen
jetzt ohne jede weitere Debatte aus der
Kernenergie Auskommen mit den was es
wolle wir hätten hier alleine an dieser
zwei Standorte noch für mehrere Monate
Rest Brennstäben könnten wenigstens den
nächsten Winter noch sicher abdecken sie
wissen dieser zwei liefern dann die 15%
der bayerischen Stromversorgung und zwar
auch in der Zeit wo im Windräder nicht
liefern wo Sonne nicht liefert gerade in
der kalten Winter Nacht hat dieser zwei
immer zuverlässig funktioniert und
solange die Brücke nicht gebaut ist die
neue Brücke nicht gebaut ist darf man
die alte Brücke nicht abbrechen aber da
sind sie schnell da sind sie am Werk bei
den anderen Dingen nicht also heute
Fehlentscheidung der Bundesregierung das
über diese Dinge nicht mehr diskutiert
wird
ja meine Damen und Herren es sind
schwarze Tage für Deutschland es sind
hochrisikotage es ist eine
hochrisikostrategie die die
Bundesregierung hier fährt weil sie
einerseits Deutschland in
energiepolitische Abhängigkeit führt
indem sie die wirtschaftliche Stabilität
gefährdet und in dem Sie jedes
Anschlusskonzept vermissen lässt
Anschlusskonzept nämlich bei der Frage
wie auch Technologieführerschaft
Energiefragen in der Zukunft ausschaut
fakt ist Deutschland galt über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte als weltweit mit führend bei
den zivilen Anwendungen der Kerntechnik
in Bayern ist 1957 der erste
Forschungsreaktor in Garching entstanden
und das war ein gewisser Weise die Wiege
die hier gelegt wurde dafür dass Bayern
und auch Deutschland einen
industriepolitischen Aufschwung über
viele Jahre nehmen konnten wir wollen in
Bayern uns aus der kein Energie aus der
Kerntechnik nicht verabschieden
unabhängig von dieser Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung wir investieren weiter
in unsere Infrastruktur Natur in die
wissenschaftsinfrastrukturen die
Forschungsinfrastruktur wir haben
hervorragende Einrichtungen lieber
Hubert einwanger mit dem
Max-Planck-Institut für Plasma Physik in
Garching mit der Technischen Universität
München mit vielen weiteren
Einrichtungen in ganz Bayern die in der
Kerntechnik ausbilden und auch weiter
investieren es geht hier um Fragen der
nuklearen Sicherheit es geht um Fragen
der nuklearen Kompetenz es geht auch um
Fragen der nuklearen Anwendungen und
Innovation viele neue Werkstoffe viele
neue Materialien Batterien der Zukunft
der sogar Impfstoffe der Zukunft sind
mit Hilfe der Kerntechnik mit Hilfe
beispielsweise des Forschungsreaktors
heute möglich und wir wollen diese
Technologie deswegen weiter fördern wir
setzen wie ist der Ministerpräsident
gesagt hat auch auf die neuen Formen der
Kerntechnologie es wird in diesen Tagen
nämlich genau am kommenden Montag ein
Studiengang starten zur Kernfusion an
der Technischen Universität München die
nebenbei bemerkt inzwischen einen
Großteil der Ausbildungsleistungen
erbringt nicht nur für sein sondern für
ganz Deutschland was kerntechnische
Kompetenz angeht wir wollen auch bei
diesen neuen Technologien wie der neuen
Kernfusion mit dabei sein und so wie
damals 1957 mit dem Forschungsreaktor in
Garching Neuland beschritten wurde
wollen wir auch aus Bayern heraus einen
Beitrag leisten mit der Mission einer
neuen Kernfusion einen Grundstein dafür
zu legen dass auch in Zukunft unsere
Energieversorgung sauber und sicher ist
dies beides hat sich über viele Jahre
verbunden miterkennen Technik in Bayern
und wir setzen darauf dass dies auch in
der Zukunft so sein wird deswegen werden
wir hier unsere Bemühungen noch mal
intensivieren sowohl in die Ausbildung
der jungen Menschen wie auch bei der
Frage wie wir Innovation und Technologie
in diesem Feld weiter stärken können für
den Moment wie gesagt im Moment dunkle
Tage für Deutschland und mit der zarten
Hoffnung dass die Kerntechnik die
herkömmliche vielleicht dass da das
letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen ist
aber gleichzeitig der großen Hoffnung
dass wir vielleicht einen Beitrag dazu
leisten können das mit neuen Formen der
keinen Technologie tatsächlich die
Zukunftsfragen der Energie der sauberen
Energie und vor allem das Klimaschutzes
und der wirtschaftsstabilität aus Bayern
heraus mit beantwortet werden können
sie werden die rechtlichen Möglichkeiten
ausrüsten um die Kernkraft sorgen werden
Sie bei der rückbaugenehmigung wann soll
die kommen wann haben Sie die Vorräte
die verzögert werden also wir verhalten
uns natürlich rechts treu die Rechtslage
ist eindeutig die Kernenergie endet am
Sonntag sozusagen in der Nacht soll
Samstag auf Sonntag das ist auch
irreversibel jetzt im Moment ganz klar
aber es gibt ja eine Reihe von
landesrechtlichen fragen wann wie was
gemacht werden soll und das schauen wir
uns alle sehr genau an alles rechts treu
aber alles im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten
die wir haben noch genau anzuschauen
weil ehrlicherweise glaube ich dass wir
möglicherweise schon im Winter wieder
eine neue Debatte führen und darauf
sollte man vorbereitet sein um
möglicherweise doch schnell wieder das
Anwerfen zu können wenn es ernster wird
ich kann mir vorstellen dass im nächsten
Winter die Energie Situation noch mal
sehr gefährlich wird und die Hubert
einfach mal sagt die Windstille kalte
Nacht die ist unser Problem
nicht das schöne Sonnentag nicht Stürme
an der Nordsee und an der Ostsee sondern
tatsächlich die Windstille Nacht und
dafür braucht es eine Sicherheit im
Übrigen auch für die gesamte
Industrieproduktion und für die
Netzspannung und insofern glaube ich wir
verhalten uns recht soll an das geht ja
gar nicht ja aber wir schauen uns die
zuständigen Behörden das macht die
zuständigen Aufsichtsbehörden schauen
sich jede einzelne Schritt rechtlich
genauer an
vielen Dank
wie sieht denn die Hoffnung die sie beim
Mann jetzt hier wecken wie können sie
denn die überhaupt konkret einlösen
die grüne grüne mit Gewalt durch anders
Möglichkeit die Anlagen können nicht
weiter betrieben werden
ist widerlegt eine ganze fahrlangs von
Argumenten sind in sich zusammengefallen
wenn es notwendig ist dann wird auch die
die Weiterbetrieb gehen wenn man es will
zugegebenermaßen mit jedem halben Jahr
länger schwieriger und das je länger es
dauert desto länger dauert auch die
Reaktivierung
ich teile Ihre Auffassung übrigens dass
das dass das
fachliche Know-How durch Mitarbeiter
Mitarbeiter eine der größten
Herausforderungen dran ist Brennstäbe zu
bestellen ist möglich es wäre sinnvoll
da dann Plan zu entwickeln Brennstäbe zu
bestellen es gibt auch Möglichkeiten
technische Updates jederzeit zu machen
glaube es gab eine Aussage dieser Tage
in den Medien von Tüftler sagt bis Ende
des Jahrzehnts können die jetzigen
Anlagen auch gut weiter betrieben werden
für die Mitarbeiter Mitarbeiter ist es
einfach deswegen traurig weil sie seit
Jahrzehnten hervorragende Arbeit machen
erfolgreich sicher und das muss man
einfach mal sagen und der Wahrheit muss
man sich stellen klimastrom ist halt aus
Kernenergie CO2 anders zu bewerten als
aus Kohle die Realität so wie gesagt der
Grund warum man eine ändere Strategie
bringt Hubert aiwang hat es in dem
eigenen Formen dargestellt
wir sind anders als 20 11 wir haben 20
11 übrigens vor allem Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet nicht sicher waren zum
Beispiel beim Flugzeugabsturz das war
bei dieser eins die Frage dieser zwei
ist da ganz anders strukturiert die Welt
hat sich aber dramatisch verändert die
Klima Herausforderung ist um ein
exponentiellen Faktor höher geworden
auch die entsprechenden Gutachter haben
das gezeigt und die Abhängigkeit und die
Unabhängigkeit machen von bisherigen
Energieformen zwingt uns dazu alte
Positionen von 11 Jahren zu überdenken
und so wie sie in ihrem Leben wie wir
alle Entscheidungen treffen die
vielleicht vor zehn Jahren gut waren die
man jetzt neu justieren muss ist das
hier an der Stelle auch deswegen braucht
es einen Plan es braucht auf jeden Fall
von der Bundesliga Stundenplan B es ist
der absolut
unprofessionell und aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht verständlich
wenn die Bundesregierung nicht zu dem
abschaltplan auch einen Plan B einen
möglichen wieder anfahrplan entwickeln
muss sonst steht man nämlich im Winter
völlig leer da das ist ein reiner grüner
Blankoscheck der hier erteilt wird ein
gewissermaßen ein grüner Blindflug und
das kann so auf Dauer kann ein Land das
ist ein Wohlstand garantieren soll und
ein Land das auf dem Niveau auch weiter
Energie braucht wir brauchen E-Mobilität
Bayern ist es für eine Lande Immobilität
auch Wärmepumpen brauchen übrigens Strom
und zwar sehr viel
und dafür brauchen wir auch
Stromerzeugung und es gibt jedenfalls
auf absehbare Zeit für die Grundlast
keinen Ersatz und Kohle ist im Vergleich
dazu kein moralisch vertretbarer
meine Damen und Herren das waren live
aus Niederbayern die Statements der
bayerischen Staatsregierung der
Ministerpräsident der
Wirtschaftsminister und der
Wissenschaftsminister zur Abschaltung
von Isa 2 Atomkraftwerk Isar 2 einer von
beiden Reaktoren der andere ist schon
länger vom Netz am Samstag dann das
Finale für die Abschaltung der
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland die
letzten drei werden vom Netz gehen
Emsland Neckarwestheim und eben Isar 2
die Debatte dazu um die Frage der
Abschaltung und des korrekten
Zeitpunktes die hat längst begonnen und
wir wollen ein bisschen über
Energiesicherheit aber auch um diese
Debatte in Deutschland sprechen deswegen
freue ich mich dass wir verbunden sind
in Windhagen mit ähm Professor Frank
Umbach Politikwissenschaftler und
Experte für Energiesicherheit an der
Universität Bonn Herr Umbach ich glaube
wir müssen da ein bisschen beginnen bei
der Emotionalität die diese Debatte in
Deutschland hat und mit der wir auch ein
wenig beugt werden und wahrscheinlich
auch ein wenig belächelt werden warum
diese Ideologie in Deutschland
nun ich glaube die DNA der Grünen Partei
wenn man einfach geschichtlich noch mal
zurückgeht ist ja im wesentlichen aus
einer antinuklearen Bewegung entstanden
sowohl gegen Atomwaffen aber auch die
zivilen Nutzung und wir haben ja im
letzten Herbst bei der schwierigen Frage
der Laufzeitverlängerung jetzt bis zum
April schon erlebt wie schwierig diese
Debatte innerhalb der Grünen Partei ist
ein Teil der Grünen Jugend aber auch
Herr Harbeck zeigt sich da ähm deutlich
flexibler und hat die Notwendigkeit der
Versorgungssicherheit seinerzeit erkannt
aber der Gegenwind auch von Herrn
triptin und anderen die gesagt haben ich
bin dein in die Grüne Partei
eingestiegen sozusagen als Mitglied ich
habe mein ganzes Leben lang gegen
Kernenergie gekämpft und das hat das
seinerzeit schon zu ganz erheblichen
innerparteilichen Auseinandersetzungen
geführt und der Kompromiss war dass man
sich noch mal durchgerungen hat
zu dieser Laufzeitverlängerung bis zu
diesem Sonntag aber eben nicht darüber
hinaus und hat das sozusagen auch als
Bedingung wie eine Kanon gegenüber den
ampelkoalitionspartnern sozusagen
als Bedingung genannt darauf hat man
sich jetzt geeinigt und das will man
durchziehen unabhängig von der Frage wie
ist die Versorgungssicherheit in
Deutschland und die wiederum hängt aber
nicht nur von Deutschland selbst ab
sondern ja auch von Frankreich wo die
Situation der 26 in 2022
herausgenommenen Atomkraftwerke aus dem
Betrieb eben bis heute nicht besser
geworden ist da hatte man auch über die
letzten Monate gehofft dass zumindestens
mehrere drei vier Kernkraftwerke wieder
ins Netz gehen das ist noch mal jetzt
verlängert worden so dass sich die
Situation hier nicht verbessert hat und
wir hatten im letzten Sommer ja auch
ganz erhebliche Probleme in Europa auch
in Deutschland mit Wasserkraftwerken bis
hoch nach Norwegen wo norwegische
Regierung ein neues Gesetz beschlossen
hat und hat gesagt wenn wir noch mal
eine solche Situation aufdreht dass wir
nicht genügend Wasserkraft für die
Stromerzeugung Norwegen haben dann
sozusagen werden wir haben wir jetzt
eine gesetzliche Handhabe um auch den
Export von Strom nach Großbritannien
oder Deutschland einzuschränken also da
bestehen ganz erhebliche Fragezeichen
auch mit gegenüber einem Winter wo wir
ja nicht wissen wie kalt er wird der war
in den letzten Jahren relativ moderaten
relativ mild aber das ist keine gewährt
dass das im nächsten Winter so bleibt
und an dieser Stelle können wir auch
noch mal festhalten dass der
grundsätzliche Ausstiegsbeschluss ja
schon vor sehr langer Zeit gefahren ist
vor über 20 Jahren von einer rot-grünen
Bundesregierung da im Jahr 2002 aber sie
haben es angesprochen das ganze ist kein
singuläres Ereignis sondern man muss
Energiesicherheit europaweit Denken die
Richtung sozusagen die viele andere
Länder gehen lautet auf Neubau von
Reaktoren wenn wir aber auf
Energiesicherheit jetzt mal gehen es
gibt zum Beispiel jetzt diesen Gedanken
im Raum nicht nur diese drei Kraft Werke
sondern bis zu sechs in einer Reserve zu
halten vor dem Hintergrund des nächsten
Winters für wie tragfähig halten Sie so
einen Gedanken
nun wenn der politische Wille da wäre in
der Koalition auch bei den Grünen dann
glaube ich würde man über all die
vermeintlichen Bedenken die man immer
geäußert hat hinweggehen können das
haben ganze Reihe von Gutachten auch
technische Experten immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen wir haben den amerikanischen
Konzern westinghaus der im letzten
Frühjahr der Bundesregierung mehrfach
angeboten hat Brennstäbe zu reservieren
und zu verkaufen Ende letzten Jahres all
diese Angebote hat man ja nicht zur
Kenntnis genommen wir bleiben auf jeden
Fall Grundlast abhängig und wenn wir
jetzt keine Kernkraftwerke länger laufen
lassen dann müssen wir umso mehr Kohle
und Gaskraftwerke laufen lassen und in
der Perspektive auch nach 2025 ist ja
auch eben angedacht wegen diesem
Grundlast Problem dass wir tatsächlich
auch mit bis zu 10 oder 15 neue
Gaskraftwerke dann bauen müssten und
diese Diskussion der Abwägung lassen wir
Laufzeiten verl kann oder bauen wir
wirklich in so einem großen Ausmaß auch
neue Gaskraftwerke diese Diskussion wird
nicht offen geführt diese Entscheidung
ist immer wieder letztendlich auch
vertagt worden was auch problematisch
ist mit dem Blick auf die
Stromversorgung Sicherheit 2030 die
entgegen der offiziellen Meinung des
Wirtschaftsministers eben keineswegs
gesichert ist also auch Perspektive
stellen sich hier eine ganze Reihe von
Fragen wie diese Grundlast gesichert
werden muss Herr Umbach letzter knapper
Gedanke
Klimaschutzziele sowieso jetzt
angesichts dieser Überlegung dieses
skizziert haben aber hier war auch der
Wissenschaftsminister von das Freistaat
Bayern dabei neue Kernfusion welche
Chance geben Sie dieser Idee vielleicht
noch eine knappe Einschätzung
es gibt durchaus kleinere technologische
Durchbrüche aber niemand erwartet
eigentlich ich kenne keine ernsthafte
Meinung die glaubt dass wir vor 2040 15
in diesem Zeitraum hier tatsächlich
kahnfusion als konkrete
energietechnologische Optionen im
industriellen Maßstab bereits zur
Verfügung haben also das wird sicherlich
dauern könnte die Energielandschaft dann
tatsächlich
grundlegend auch noch mal verändern aber
in der Perspektive auch der
klimapolitischen Zielsetzung bis 2014
und 2050 hilft uns das wahrscheinlich
eben nicht und deswegen müssen wir auf
die anderen Optionen schauen und wenn
wir eben diese Laufzeit Verlängerung
jetzt nicht noch mal entsprechend
verändern über den nächsten Winter
hinweg dann bleiben uns eben er nur
Kohle und Gaskraftwerke und das ist
einerseits klimapolitisch die
schlechtere Lösung und das ist ganz
bestimmt eben auch mit Blick auf Neubau
von Gaskraftwerken die teuere Option
oder bzw Laufzeit verlängert die
günstigere Option aber der Bau von
Gaskraft werden die teuere ganz
herzlichen Dank für ihre Hintergründe
und Einschätzung frank umwach war das
Politikwissenschaftler und Energie
Experte für Energiesicherheit an der
Universität Bonn Messi und danke nach
Wintertagen
bitte schön schönen Tag noch gerne
meine Damen und Herren und wir springen
in die Lücke wir springen ein der Titel
unserer nächsten Dokumentation und wir
springen dann auch wieder ein bei
Phoenix vor Ort 16.45 live unser Stop in